hey everybody and welcome to hands down
the most engaging wild ride with stevo
yet
we are talking engagement because this
is my fiancee lux right and yeah maybe
you know her from all of our naked
photos on instagram
maybe you don't either way i love this
woman she is the [ __ ]
and she opens up so much we get so
personal in this episode this episode is
the [ __ ]
and when i'm taking a [ __ ]
you better believe i am well equipped
for the most healthy bowel movement
possible why because before my
[ __ ]
i put my feet on my squatty potty what
does that do that puts my knees in a
position
where
poop comes out completely and fully why
because the human body is designed not
to sit on a toilet but think about it
cavemen they crouch in the freaking
woods man that's how the body was
designed to poop and squatty potty lines
you up in that natural healthy position
otherwise you can have all kinds of
health risks if you don't poop in this
position and the answer is squatty potty
man telling you dude it's a complete
bowel movement for total poop health
and you got to have it so how do you get
it you go to squattypotty.com
stevo they got all kinds of cool stuff
and it's a really fun website plus if
you use squattypotty.com
20 off your order man i've been using
this for years dude
literally like eight years since i got
my first one and i never turned back
neither will you so head to
squattypotty.com stevo right now and
let's get into it
that's the air tag dude we should do one
where you like stick it up your ass
and try to find you
like a little a hunt oh wow that is
funny just like you put it up your butt
and you just run into the bushes and
it's like dark out or
[ __ ] up my butt something
into a cornfield and we gotta like find
you like we're geologists tracking
bigfoot dude the sasquatch suit
and then you like going to the forest
like you're [ __ ] sasquatch yeah and
we're trying to find you like wait
for sure let's just do this okay are we
rolling on all cameras we sure are scott
ladies and gentlemen
lux's right
here
hey favorite hi guys hi yeah hello
welcome to the website so far yeah i'm
over here
um yeah thanks paul has a great question
prepared for you okay that's right right
off the bat yeah we're in so what's your
favorite sexual position
yeah let's warm up a little bit well no
i think a lot of people don't know how
you and steve met
i think that's a good start they got to
know that right we met on set yeah on a
job
you were there i was there and then you
saw it
and what attracted you to steve uh how
well it's like obviously his looks are
attractive but i was so impressed with
his overall awareness of everything that
was going on during the shoot i mean
everything and how he handled it how
dedicated he was to filming
um it was it was impressive what was the
shoot oh i'm sorry
she says i couldn't believe what an
attention [ __ ] he was
not on that level i mean like all the
departments like you were just so aware
of everything
it was like you were like a dedicated
crew member like and not just like
typical talent on set like it was
impressive so would you ask him when he
went up to him
because i don't think i've ever talked
about this
but
when i remember the first time you guys
met okay and then you walked away and
steve's like
is she a dopey
yeah
is she a dopey yeah i mean like are you
a nug yeah
are you like a donor no like like a dope
good-looking chick oh okay
like are you are you like do you
remember saying this to me i don't
remember saying that
i i think what i remember is that they
had like three
models like paid to be there to look hot
i think they were dancers yeah and i was
like dude they paid these chicks into
their car like they're not even as hot
as
luck's over here
thanks and then what and then and then
you reached out to steve
she went okay to be clear lux was
wearing um
a uh a ring on her wedding finger yeah
like the the marriage i mean and wearing
and so i i understood that she was taken
and i was being respectful yeah yeah and
i
i felt like when we had our goodbye i
felt like it was like a very like
it was like cool so nice working with
you and it was very like dragged out
like we just kept like talking repeating
things like well yeah well i hope to see
you again like okay cool have a good
night and then i was just like what the
heck is happening yeah i just like i
felt like we did have a connection
overall in the shoot like we kept it
professional
um but then like a week later i was just
still felt like
it was just different so i was like i'm
gonna shoot my shot and just see
and then you guys went on a date she
slid into the dms yeah and what was the
dm
it was just like hey it was so great
working with you like uh
you know yeah i specified the what the
job was so he would know it was me
um just in case he read it i don't know
and then um and i signed it like a
little flirty i think like
something with like a exo or a heart
emoji or something so it wasn't like so
that's a flirty move it wasn't like you
know trying to suck your dick but it
wasn't like i just wanted is there an
emotion for that
i want to say banana in the water
eggplant and
before you reached out to steve did you
reach out to one like one of your
girlfriends or like do you think i'm
going to ask him out no no you just did
it
and then where was your first date
where was it yeah we went to dinner
yeah sun cafe it was a it was um
this is this vegan restaurant on uh like
ventura boulevard
and
we showed up late well i should have
been i showed up on time but i was on a
call with my agent and so like you
showed up late on the phone
[Laughter]
how late wait like you showed up but
then you sat in the parking lot and
finished your call i stood outside of
the restaurant right and uh did you give
at least give her like a
no i didn't even walk in the restaurant
until i finished the car i mean that's
late you know watching yeah i was late
the moment you walked in the restaurant
i walked out of the restaurant late
you're right thank you
and i i don't mind even saying like uh
we we had uh a european tour
which was um
some months before that
and they were
lingering
ah i mean i guess it was actually like
two months before that that it ended um
there were there were lingering issues
with uh with promoters who had actually
lost money because there were certain
shows in europe where just people
weren't stoked to go watch stevo do
comedy
and uh and and what i was on the call
doing with the agent was insisting that
those promoters got
money refunded i said i don't want to go
i never want to work with people and
have them lose money for for working
with me and so uh i was arranging like
figuring out like how much to refund to
to certain promoters which is good and
you're redeeming your tardiness
i mean did you tell her that when you
walked in there i don't know no i didn't
care like it was probably like because
they just keep fighting people
couple thousand dollars babe yeah it's
hollywood
no but we had a good dinner we talked
forever i feel like the waitress came
back like 20 times to get our order
because we were just talking the whole
time right and when she got him to go to
the bathroom oh
she was wearing these jeans
and her ass was so red oh i mean like
unbelievably red i even think she was
like oh okay you know now i'm gonna like
that's what you say even no dude it was
insane when she's like i'm gonna seal
the deal with this walk right now let
him know yeah
yeah
so was that a like let's go back to my
place kind of night or not even that
night
and what'd you guys do after that like
did you guys part ways uh well you know
lux doesn't like that i make such a big
deal out of this all the time but i was
so impressed with her because she was
like
like boiling over with enthusiasm she
was so excited about how her best friend
who's a girl named nicole
and who has
who has like two kids
two jobs you know
and just and she was like i felt like
nicole needed a break so so what i did
was i arranged with her jobs to get her
time off you know i arranged with her
her boyfriend to make sure the kids were
taken care of
like i freed up her time she doesn't
even know it and i and i bought
both of us like flights and flights to
japan and hotels wow so i could pay for
like a whole week for her to just not
have to worry about anything yeah she
needed it she never she never traveled
never been out of the country and we've
been best friends since fifth grade so
we were turning 30 i was like i want
like you know a monumental trip with her
and like i'm just gonna make it happen
so
it was it was really like uh
striking how excited she was to to do
something so selfless for for her friend
and and uh
it impacted me and then there's another
thing that she was that she talked about
which was um her dog olive
who's now our dog and and all of um
if anybody has seen the my bucket list
show all of the [ __ ] guzzler so yeah
they're familiar yeah um
the uh
the olive had like a herniated disc or
something yeah and uh yeah and and it
was like
the the the the vet says you know she
needs this back surgery or it's just we
gotta put her that put her down
and and it was like a ten thousand
dollar
and luck said i think that was the most
like the biggest purchase she ever made
was to save her dog
yeah wow
and and that was that that uh those two
things really made me think okay this is
this is an extraordinary woman
and so then did you guys make plans for
the the second date at the date or did
you say okay we walked to the car
and uh i think it gave her a kiss on the
cheeks yeah which was so cute i still to
this day i love that and
my favorite thing that you said to me i
enjoy you yeah you said that i said i
enjoy you it was so sweet yeah and
i said i enjoy you and uh i love
watching you walk away
[Laughter]
it was pretty rad it was super rad yeah
i don't remember how the second date
came about i remember the second date um
i i was performing oh that's right at
the comedy store that's right and i
think we had already made plans for to
get together for dinner and then i i
sort of added on it then i said would it
be douchey if i said you want you want
to come watch me perform comedy
right which wasn't you handled it so
well it wasn't douchey at all i loved it
it was cute and uh i remember thinking
like oh my god i like what this so so
the second date was at hugo's
and we went from hugo's to
the comedy store and and as i parked in
the comics it was like i'm pulling into
this parking spot and this guy like was
like dude i was about to park there like
and and then it was he was like
challenging my
our masculinity date yeah and then it's
but then the guy has like a girl come
over and i was like oh i'll get out the
car like we're we're doing it and i'm
like and i'm like it's it's not that big
of a deal to me but but common sense
dictates to me that it was my parking
spot because like i i got into it first
i don't care i was gonna park there like
well you didn't and i did and so i'm
sorry i don't know what to tell you
right but i don't want to look like a
dick and i also don't want to look like
a [ __ ] right right so like i was just
so i was just so maddened by this and i
was
and and i
yeah i could tell you were you were just
like i was like don't don't [ __ ]
put me in this position when i'm on the
second date that's something that's
important to me and i think i i turned
to lux and i was just like
am i am i crazy or is this ridiculous
like like i
am in the spot so
whatever the [ __ ] he's talking about
makes no sense and we agreed that i
wasn't crazy and i think that that's
what that that was very helpful because
rather than just you know knee-jerk
reacts and weight like i kind of checked
in with lux yeah and we sort of
handled it together in a way that made
sense and it was like and i was like hey
you know what dude
i think this is pretty silly but go away
i think i gave him the spot yeah we did
yeah because you never want to leave
your car because who knows what
right because yeah all right
and then you leave your car and walk
away yeah and the next thing you know
something happens to it
show up
and now we joke about it like i was
totally gonna park there
right and so then we went into the
comedy club and i and i performed my
celebrity cocaine stories
and what'd you think of that lux i don't
remember that
i'm glad you didn't ask me whatever what
you performed because i i didn't
remember
and then when was your first kiss
i will never forget our first kiss but
i'll tell you we're doing a whole lot
more than kissing these days and we are
having an absolute blast why because i
found out about blue chew tablets
they're chewable tablets with the exact
same active ingredient as both viagra
and cialis but they're chewable and they
only cost a fraction of the price
and man i'm telling you dude it's a lot
of fun
with the kind of a boner you get from
these babies and how do you get these
babies well the good news is you don't
have to go into some weird awkward
doctor visit in person no dude you go to
bluechew.com and you consult with one of
their medical providers right there and
it takes no time man then you get these
babies on the way you know what's even
crazier dude
if you use the promo code stevo
bluechew.com you get an entire month's
supply of these delicious chewable boner
tablets
and you don't even have to pay for them
a whole month's supply for free
all you pay is five dollars for shipping
man
you gotta try it dude go to
bluetooth.com use the promo code stevo
get an entire month's supply of these
babies completely for free pay nothing
but five dollars for shipping and get to
having a wicked boner and having a
really good time
now let's talk about that first kiss
like about a month after we met yeah we
dated for a month well we met on january
7th of
2017 our first kiss was february 5th of
2017. so two days shy of a month after
meeting wow how many dates was that
how many days no it might have only been
our third date wow you think so but that
feels long like to wait a whole month
was it like for everybody
i didn't check her out
right so you were oh you had to check i
i had a checkered past i thought you
said i had to check her pass and i was
like wait i don't know yeah
it takes a month for the report to come
back
yeah that's green light yeah so you were
kind of like i'm gonna i want to do this
one right sort of is that how you were
approaching that time i
had a terrible track record with
relationships i was very candid with lux
about that i uh
you know and yeah i very much wanted to
kind of stick to a dating plan and and
do things
in a responsible way
and uh and be like honest and
transparent
what was your move like did you like uh
brush your hair back and then go with
the kiss
we were watching super bowl at a
restaurant that we
we had gone there before right or was
that our first time
it's probably our first time but but the
thing okay it was a super bowl day the
first kiss it was super bowl game we
were actually it was during the super
bowl yeah i just couldn't stand it tom
brady's so hot
he's like i'm getting hot over here
it was all very natural and organic and
just it was cool
yeah it was a good kisser the difference
was on that date the difference was that
we didn't meet at like a restaurant or
anything like she came over to the house
and and so i could take her on the hike
across the street
we went on the hike and then we came
back to the house she went first on the
hike
[Laughter]
i don't know
we have a guest room in the house which
is like supposed to be a kid's bedroom
oh yeah it's got this like little hidden
like sort of like fort kind of like with
this tiny it's it's a weirdest little
thing yeah i showed it deluxe and we we
crawled into this little kids
kind of fort space yeah that would have
been a pretty dope spot yeah you're the
first one yeah yeah you could have
just like waiting around in there i was
like so what are we doing in here
wait at this house yeah
where is that what do you mean we'll
crawl in there later all right
we'll go in there maybe we'll see
it's a really cool little little thing
and yeah like that would have made sense
but then we would i think we were like
running late for the kickback the super
bowl yeah you sped like a [ __ ]
we got there just in time for kickoff
was that the first time you've seen him
actually drive drive
actually that was an impressive driving
moment because it was like time we need
to get there and he drove well
and yeah in retrospect that's probably
the best driving you've ever done
because you're the worst i'm not a good
driver
that's for sure um see and then we made
out with uh
during the super bowl
and then we came back to the house
and we made out with each other's
peepees
okay so same night yes
to the pee-pee just straight in
the batter's deck to third base
yeah
knocked it out of the park with that one
and um
did
um then then
like immediately there was no more like
pacing ourselves right and like you know
then i moved in
and then really
i mean
i was in a position where i was looking
for a new place
um and i did get an apartment because i
because i was looking for a new place it
would have just been weird she was in
this awkward living situation with like
an uh an
old
like with an x where things went
sideways and she was like stuck still
living there she was like super
uncomfortable and she just needed to get
the hell out she was definitely looking
for a new place and then this happened
with us
and uh
it would have been very easy for her to
say hey you know what i'll worry about
getting placed later i'm kind of having
a good time with this guy you know like
i'll just stay with him
but she was sensitive to
like not putting like undue pressure on
the relationship like like what if
things aren't really going well she
really wanted her own sovereignty she
wanted her own
so so she got this apartment and we we
affectionately referred to the apartment
as her storage unit yeah i stayed there
maybe four nights out of the year that i
had it really maybe maybe four nights
that's being generous yeah so what you
moved in there
yeah and then you met steve like all in
the same no i haven't been moving
she found the apartment after we met we
yeah wow yeah before our first date i
had just come from like an apartment
viewing just to i was actively trying to
move and
yeah but it was important to me to get
an apartment it just made sense
to not put that pressure on the
relationship it's a good move
where are you originally from
oceanside in stockton
two or nine babies 209.
uh what what ages
stockton was
till i was 11 and then oceanside was
until high school and then i how was it
growing up in stockton until 11. did you
get into a lot of fights or did you
not a lot of fights um not a lot of
fights not like i never like fought like
girls but i was definitely not i was i
was getting bad like stockton's not an a
great
city or when i was there it wasn't it
was rough a lot of gangs like
i heard a lot of violence
did it
i don't know
my memories of it which
more recently i've i've adapted to like
that's where i'm from like own it kind
of deal um but
it was yeah it was a rough spot so and
we were poor so it was like you know
there was
it was a little rough growing up there
but then you moved to ocean crazy
and how long were you an oceanside for
junior high in high school
and then what'd you do after high school
i went to fit em the college fashion
institute of design and merchandising
how do you know
uh my aunt noni's a guidance counselor
okay so i know i don't know noni hillier
noni isn't that a name for her
well that so that college they have two
campuses or multiples um but i went one
year in san diego one year in la and
once i got to la state here so i've been
here for over 13 years and what was your
major in
visual communications
and that's for like and then how did you
get into doing sets
which is what i yeah it's
like relative to my major so it's i
bounced around a lot i didn't i went i
didn't go straight from like school to
what i wanted to do i
did like retail and body piercing
because it's like
everybody at school it was like advised
to have an internship but i was like i'm
i'm trying to i have to have a full-time
job and i'm going to school full-time
like i can't work for free like who the
[ __ ] can do an internship like mm-hmm
but um body piercing
yeah how long did you do that for not a
long time i worked there for two and a
half years but i only did body piercing
for about six months and
some of the craziest [ __ ] i've ever seen
even still like to this day is like
working there piercing just crazy you
pierce a lot of nipples crazy [ __ ] did
you pierce [ __ ] and kicks yeah and
it's like
some girl came in one time on her period
and like didn't have a tampon in or
anything was just like
blood everywhere and i we were just like
like you couldn't wait five [ __ ] days
like what do you why do you need to get
your vagina pierced right now yeah but
like
did she do the [ __ ] or the labia the
[ __ ]
that's got to hurt that's gnarly yeah
you ever pierced a
prince albert
so
i didn't but this guy would come in to
get it stretched like his he had like a
ladder there's like multiple piercings
on the shaft of his penis and he would
get them stretched get what stretch what
do you mean
so that it didn't like heal over just
just give it a tug
just pull on it
you guys do stretching right
i don't know it's like lotion on it
you can't just just stretch it just
stretch it stretch it over your wrist
yeah you waited till after hours
yeah he only came in at night
[Laughter]
stretch armstrong tickled my body
it's called a ladder when you get like
multiple piercings on the shaft of your
penis so you have like the shaft of your
penis and you have multiple piercings
okay and then he would come and get each
piercing stretched why still don't get
stretched which way like the whole
the hole okay so you kind of gotta like
work it a little bit
oh you mean a boner
with your tongue stretch it up and then
stretch it down
was that the weirdest thing that's
happened to you um
i mean it was crazy like people would
pass out like this guy came in to get
his lips pierced and he was like uh
um in the service or x mariner
um but he
got his first lip pierce like the first
piercing and then he went to do the
second one and he passed out
and when he came back he was like
like in combat and like my other piercer
had to like hold him down and he was
like just not with us like you could
tell he was like wide-eyed and like
ready to fight and we had to be like you
okay you're okay like you're an
oceanside like you just got a piercing
you passed out you're okay like
and then another guy we thought he
[ __ ] died like i went like he was out
for so long
and turning blue and not breathing like
i went over to the phone to call 9-1-1
and then he finally came to
and when he woke up he was just puking
everywhere and i was just like oh my god
we like made him stay at the
shop for like two hours until he was
okay and like ordered food for him and
just people passing out all the time
like big dudes coming in to get their
nipples pierced and just dropping to the
ground and
it was crazy it was a crazy
job you ever haven't do you have any
weird piercings not weird but
no i have my tongue pierced forever
which is probably still open but i would
have to stretch it
yeah
but yeah nothing else it's too crazy my
belly button i've had my belly button
pierced since i was 14. and
yeah
is it still pierced
it's still there do you stretch it yeah
all right
so because lex has this past as a
body
modification
professional
um
she knows about all of the blood-borne
pathogens all the stuff that you have to
you know learn that's why you're so
right all the things that you ignore yes
exactly right so when we were in orlando
lex came like you know on a few
tour
stops that were strung together
and after a show this kid's like dude i
brought a tattoo gun man oh will you
tattoo me
and i remember being late at night i'm
doing a meet and greet for the second
time after two shows and like he waited
until after this wait until then he was
polite he waited until the very end i
was like all right dude look
it's the last thing i want to do is more
work but
i'm gonna do this so fast i'm gonna
tattoo yo mama's name on your butt cheek
and we're gonna get done get it done so
fast i gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
but i'm gonna tattoo you
so i did i thought it was kind of funny
and uh and then i come back to the hotel
room like oh it looks check it out i
gave this kid a tattoo and i showed her
a little instagram story yeah she says
you tattooed somebody without wearing
gloves
yeah you had and you're like it's fine
it's fine and i look at your hands and
you have ink all the [ __ ] everywhere
underneath your nails and your and you
had like that's an exaggeration i don't
you also had a cut on your thumb and i
was just like well this is
weird not having sex without a condom
for six months i need to get tested like
i don't know who this random kid is like
you know give him the benefit of the
doubt but i'm not letting you put it in
me without a condom
and you were not having sex without a
condom for six months yeah
i'm like
what are you talking about yeah you were
yeah you thought i was the crazy one we
actually boned with a rubber yeah for
like a month
that is
we went a long time i remember
you are like it's fine honey like he's a
former heroin addict
oh my god that's right
you might want to tell us that before he
starts tattooing you
and he was like ah dude it's all good
you
i do i'm so glad that i'm
who i am and made you not we went for a
long time we went i wanted to say for a
long time five months like five minutes
we went for a long time and then there
was one night when we were in the hot
tub together and it was things got a
little bit hot
and then what and it was great because
it was like yeah it was like six months
of [ __ ] condom sex
and then jacuzzi sex yeah exactly like
there's chlorine in here it'll do
something
yeah i think yeah i think we even well
looks you're i mean your tolerance for
what steve's does is
insane like just surprising and
especially the like the pe belly flop
that we did the other day it was like
yeah i can't believe it was a lot i got
pushed to a like
a brink that i've never been
pushed to ever in my life and i do you
know long crazy
physical days at work and but
your line
moved much like when you first started
dating steve you're like oh like were
you saying like that i could never
handle but then six months later like
here we are like he's [ __ ] on the
balcony
sounds crazy man but let me tell you
something really crazy i stayed up last
night until six o'clock this morning
because i'm finishing up my new book and
i'm telling you i obliterated my first
book this thing is so good but how am i
operating just so well and like hey man
chilling dude because not only do i
drink coffee i drink four sigmatic
coffee this is made with functional
mushrooms like lions maine and it keeps
me totally on point man it keeps me
energized but not cracked out and
jittery
right no gnarly crash
and it keeps me functional because we
got those functional mushrooms man
they're actually proven by some studies
to regenerate the brain which is good
for a guy like me who hits his head all
the time but yeah man i'm telling you
dude this is delicious coffee
and it's really healthy for you i was
worried that i was drinking too much
coffee not anymore man i pound this
stuff till six in the morning i don't
even care and they're they've got a
special deal just for the listeners of
the wild ride podcast if you go to
foursigmatic.com slash stevo you get up
to 40 percent off of any mushroom coffee
bundle
and free shipping plus when you're there
you'll see they've got all kinds of dope
stuff like mushroom cacao mix and how
about the plant-based protein
powder with superfoods come on dude
that's for repairing yourself these
people are tuned in to your health and
you got to try it so go to 4sigmatic.com
stevo
and again that's going to get you up to
40 off of any coffee bundle mushroom
coffee
and all kinds of great products man so
take care of yourself take care of this
podcast go to 4sigmatic.com
now let's get back to it
i feel like my lines are all over the
place i think the only thing that
shifted is uh your nudity
because you know being in an intimate
relationship i wasn't like so stoked
that you just had your
dick out for certain things and uh we we
worked past that so my line my line
moved on that
but everything else is kind of
situational i would say so
did your line move on uh clona willy
and that's no no so so for the audience
people looking i i had a clone of willy
sent to the house
why not not this no i wanted to sell
stevo's dick but monks had the idea but
here's yeah i had the id i told him that
his package was so beautiful that i
wanted it like
basically cloned like you're saying like
[ __ ] and balls like i want the whole
thing like i love it
yeah i love it all i want it all and
he's like no no no and then scott comes
up with the idea
to sell autographed stevo
actual dildos
and then you're like oh that's a great
idea
[Laughter]
did you ever clone it
no because you still have that yeah
that's just in our kitchen and just
hanging out
it's been in the kitchen for like well
over a year yeah which i love that we
just have like a dildo thing in the
kitchen your dad's like
yeah it's great so you're not budging on
that we can't sell stevo dicks yet
or ever
i mean
or if we give you a wow dude i feel like
scott's really making some progress
right what if we gave you five percent
oh there you go she's sharing the
profits
it's a code can we get a verbal
confirmation you can talk about it later
it's a co-production but what if we show
lux on the packaging and give her more
of a percentage
yeah
10 negotiations but i don't yeah i mean
honestly it's like you know it is so
much of our life and you specifically is
like shared with the public like it is
kind of nice to have something be
between us so if it's you know
i'm not tripping over selling molds of
my penis you could do your balls though
and like you know how they they hang
them off of trucks and stuff like if it
was your balls
that would be good because
yeah even though i love it oh yeah
because balls are more symbolic to like
you yeah right right you're all balls
they call me all balls yeah i mean that
makes sense for his who he is okay
[Music]
of his well you have the willie upstairs
for when he's on tour
so
uh these guys are just i feel like this
podcast is going pretty remarkably well
oh yeah it's productive it's
productive yeah it's coming up
new merch keep it coming guys
well i mean like what surprised you most
as you got to know steve other than like
his enthusiasm for production and what
do you think would surprise other people
a lot that they don't realize about
steve because you know him more
intimately than anyone probably even
more than than we do
yes god knows him pretty intimately um
that does but we don't get the pillow
talk you know i don't know what's
well
pillow talk i thought about this the
other day is that we had the most
ridiculous
realization of each other
however long ago where you can do
beavis's voice
and i can do butthead's voice and we
were like in bed just pitch dark like
doing beavis and butt head voices to
each other
and
we tried to record it i feel like and it
didn't come out as well yeah
yeah i feel like sometimes we sometimes
late at night
we laugh so [ __ ] hard over the
dumbest weirdest [ __ ] like yeah coming
up with the next oh my god i enjoy it so
much i love when we're cracking each
other up yeah we just come up with silly
names i mean you guys know we have like
our own weird language baby talk
i mean yeah we have just like a weird
language i feel like between us for sure
it is a type of baby talk though yeah
big time but it's unique it's your own
little baby talk yeah yeah yeah
um
all right so keep coming guys well would
you
do you have any questions for her i mean
ah
i mean out of all these i feel like
we've been very nice to me
what what are we not like oh there we go
i earlier was trying to allude to the
fact that you're the worst driver ever
and you just skipped right over it yeah
let's keep going what else what are the
other worst traits of steve
well
i want to focus on the driving for a
minute because i feel like it's so it's
problematic when i'm driving
yeah when i first started working with
steve
he drove us to the airport
i almost threw up every single time he
joined the airport and obnoxiousness and
stress and then he was like stressful he
was like you drive so then i drove
and then he's losing his mind over the
thing no no he's losing his mind
the fact that the crosswalk
i went this far into the crosswalk and
because he got a red light ticket for
doing something like that if you go this
far into the crosswalk then technically
you ran a red light he will lose his
[ __ ] [ __ ]
see that i mean that lose my [ __ ] i'd
lose my [ __ ] on a lot of things dude
okay that's bizarre that you even know
that because i was so
like observing you drive and being with
you driving i'm like he's just so bad
and then i realized at one point you
stopped to do it to like get into a
parallel spot and you you stopped and
we're on like melrose like a really busy
street and and like ever just like what
the [ __ ] and then he turns his blinker
on like oh i want this spot and
everybody starts honking and i'm like i
never turn on my blinker
but the point was that you were like
i'm like you got to put on your blinker
it's like your communicator to the other
cars around you you got to give them the
heads up and then you break and you're
like
but i'm not turning yeah
i'm like yes how did you get your
driver's license
did you fail any tests i i i failed my
written test
when i first um
i
came to
california i took the written test and
uh it just wasn't in the cards for me to
drive so
but you did it but you got that
i mean here's my driving history never
even learned how to drive period until i
was about to turn 20 years old picked up
the car on my 20th birthday i got a dui
within six months wow
and then
uh
and then i didn't have my license
because i got the dui
got my license back got dui number two
within one month of getting my license
back
now i'm still on like 21 years old and
i've been driving
since i was 20.
and then what state was that and i was
living out of this car that i got my
second dui in in florida florida okay
and uh the the i was living out of the
car i got two duis the [ __ ] tags are
expired
it was just all bad news
ended up moving out to i just i was i
couldn't afford my
my probation i couldn't afford my dui
class all that [ __ ] that comes with it i
just couldn't afford it i was homeless
living out of a car
then these guys stole the car which was
a blessing
i moved to albuquerque i was like none
of my legal troubles will will follow me
to new mexico because they're not
felonies
so i lived with my sister in albuquerque
and just did not drive for two and a
half years
and then uh [ __ ] i it was years later i
got i got another car that's when i
drove to california yeah but i feel like
those problems
they just disappeared
when i went back to florida
i addressed it okay
and whatever like uh then then when i
moved to california
uh
they i find that the
you have to take a driving test to get a
license and that's what i think is what
i learned at that moment with the
parallel parking i was like oh he just
doesn't know certain things like you
just don't know certain rules of the
road like we'll be on the freeway and
it's like we're in the like lane that's
about to exit and then he's like oh he
like sees the exits coming all of a
sudden we're like five feet away from it
and then he wants to get over and i'm
like the the lines in the road thicken
up to let you know that this lane's
going to exit and he was like oh how
about that
did you guys know that
we pulled in
we pulled into a ride aid
we pulled we went into the driveway
he the the door to the ride
rite aid was right to the right
he stopped on the sidewalk and the
driveway got out of the car and went
into the rite aid and i'm sitting in the
passenger seat like
a car got an accident behind me or like
something happened to this car
the two cars behind me were screaming at
each other because they couldn't go
anywhere the guy comes over and is
trying to fight me and i'm in the
passenger seat like i don't even know
and then
and then and then like uh for some
reason like a grocery cart just rolls in
front of us hits another car oh my god
and then steve comes out your nightmare
by the way i can't imagine you in this
situation
[Applause]
and the guy's like like ready to fight
me to go stevo can i get a selfie
and yeah he takes a selfie and steve's
like gets back in the car he's like
thanks for waiting here dude i'm like
you have no idea what just happened to
me like this has happened like three or
four times exactly and that's part of
the problem is like you get away with it
because of who you are which is great
for you but like
but what was i did what was it
that i did which was wrong like i you
pulled into the you so so
for some of you you good
you go down lost siena guy you make a
ride in the rite aid right okay and then
there's you know how you like the
driveway kind of goes up and then like
your whole car kind of goes up into the
driveway and then there's a sidewalk and
then there's the parking lot
right not like
any normal driveway like has an elephant
you stopped
in the [ __ ] sidewalk oh god so like
nobody from the street can get around
you
and then the cars behind
we're like
stopping on the street there's the front
door that's what i need
yeah you were in the car it was a live
park
right right you turn the hazards on
you're good
turn on the hazard you just left you go
out and you left your door open
but then but you want to talk about open
doors
what happened because i could go on for
about that forever oh like the house
so so two so two like the the crosswalk
like running a red light ticket this is
like a month ago we were coming back
from a podcast and and he was on his
phone texting i was driving the podcast
this van back and there's almost like an
accident just coincidentally in the
intersection right i was like oh [ __ ]
dude like these cars almost hit and then
he looks up and he's like
yeah dude you really gotta you can't
park in the crosswalk i'm like
no dude these cars just almost got the
gnarliest wreck of all time he just like
glances up from his phone and thinks he
figured out what's going on and you're
like i've been driving and paying
attention and i'm way
he's like better you really can't be
parking and he's like it's a red light
ticket and i'm like
what
you're also like a liability as a
passenger because i've been driving
you're like here like read this text and
i'm like
later dude like i'm driving you're like
look at this text i just sent it to
whoever
you know it's not even look at this text
look at this text
like a gnarly accident too remember
coming back from uh
from albuquerque or whatever we saw like
shoes fly oh yeah and then we're driving
away from that you're like anyway like
read this text i just realized
like really you saw that happen yeah we
were like if we would have been 10 cars
ahead
we would have either hit this person or
like they could have i think someone got
hit on a motorcycle and then like flew
in front of other cars and then other
cars hit those cars it was it was pretty
gnarly
yeah that's scary you ever been arrested
lux
no i haven't
haven't i have not been arrested
all right so what else what else about
steve that you had it takes getting some
used to
takes getting some use too
that's such a nice way to put it
well something that's interesting is um
i i did have a motorcycle when we met
and steve
was uncomfortable with me riding around
which makes sense it's dangerous it's
the most dangerous yeah and especially
in la it's like driving in general is
dangerous like
so i got rid of my motorcycle and i
think a lot of people would find that
surprising that he
is uncomfortable in motorcycles roller
coasters
which i love both dude we were driving
from oregon in his old van roxy
and we were on like the highway and i
was going like 65 you know and we were
but we were turning a corner okay and
he's like ah
yeah and i'm like
and he's like
i'm like what are you doing he's like
and did he bring his knees up and he was
like
and he's like he's like he's like he's
just freaking me out i'm like what's
freaking you out he's like dude i'm like
am i driving too fast he's like no and
he and he's just like it just looks like
it's too crazy going around this turn
in the car and i'm like oh that's
interesting
like it's similar to a roller coaster
right it would be the effect
that i thought that was interesting yeah
so something else that um
we've talked about that i had to get
used to is um
you know
i'm obviously not famous so being with a
famous person like
he gets
so much attention everywhere we go
and it was an adjustment for me
to not get attention like you know what
being like a hot chick i respect that so
much lux was just like hey you know like
i'm a hot chick no i didn't say that
specifically well right but
have you seen this ass honey
well i mean you know like you i know i
know the amount of tension i get going
out and then it's like significantly
decreased
since i've been with you and it wasn't
an adjustment like right
it's totally true she didn't say i'm a
hot chick however she put it was
was thoroughly appropriate and it was so
candid and intimate just say like hey
you know like it's it's a thing like
being used to getting a lot of attention
as an attractive woman and then all of a
sudden you're with this guy who just
sucks all of the attention out of the
room
like uh it was tough for me and i was
like wow you know like
i respect you so much for saying that
and uh you know just yeah it was an
adjustment but i'm
yeah it was in the beginning deal but
now it's good but yeah that was
something do you get more attention from
dudes
before or after being with stevo
like
dudes hit on you now but like
before before yeah
but what about since you got your
titties
oh
yeah it's a new it's a new kind of
that's it it's a new kind of world of
getting hit on and it's
even because it's titties yeah my buddy
kevo was i was like yeah you know lux
wants to get big tits and he was like oh
dude don't let her do that and i was
like
what
and he was like man that's all i've ever
heard about man when when when a guy's
chick gets fake tits then then it ruins
the relationship because now all of a
sudden she gets so much attention from
other dudes and then if you let her get
fake tits you're gonna lose her
and i was like wow yeah we're not
working like if i don't let her get fake
tits she's not gonna let me get fixed
yeah
right
is uh
is steve is steve a good lover is he a
gentle lover is he a selfish lover
no he's a good lover he's a giver
yeah he is
we we we bicker over who gets to give
oral sex yeah really mm-hmm yeah like no
yeah we
we call it um we we call
the act of receiving
no i'm sorry that we call the act of
giving oral sex
receiving a treatment because when i
came back from peru with wendy
on the trip and i don't know if people
know this but paul briskey we met in
peru yeah on the ultimate expedition
mountain climbing thing and and that
whole expedition
was just sun baked lips cracked like the
gnarliest like exposure to the to the
the elements ever i come home from that
trip and my lips are just
my i i looked gnarly yeah and i was like
babe my lips are like uh
you know
and she's like
whenever i was like i need to eat your
[ __ ] yeah i had to heal it
with my lips yeah like you know and i
needed treatment yeah and i just ate her
box until my lips
were better and ever since then it
worked i needed treatment which means i
need to go down on you yeah
she says no but i want a treatment yeah
mm-hmm and then then
and then there's then there's a
treatment and then there's a complete
treatment
full treatment which is what
it means
finger
[Laughter]
there's a treatment that just that's
just warm up for intersex
to the finish line wow it's like booking
a spa almost like okay we'll put you
down for the complete treatment yeah
i mean i think people would expect steve
to like be into some freaky weird sex
because he's a dude he's like he'll show
you his butthole to a to a crowd of 80
000 people
so like when he's getting intimate it's
opposite
well is there anything that you want to
do that he doesn't want to do that's too
like exploratory in the bedroom
she's been like popping up in uh some
pretty rad costumes lately oh yeah are
you guys dress up that's your thing i do
i mean she'll just surprise me she she
had this one
[ __ ] thing
she pops out of the closet and she's
wearing like nothing but electrical tape
it looks like
yeah and i love how you're like that's a
very elaborate way to not have clothes
on like you're still not dressed but you
like have all these straps everywhere
it was it looked like electrical tape
and it was dope you know yeah and then
she had this other one uh
this other outfit that she popped out
what's the secret to keeping because you
guys have been together for a while like
just keeping the going on five years
five years and you guys you know seem
like you still have sex like rabbits
because i've heard you in waco texas
i heard steve giggling yeah
i was like
very quiet i feel like you did have sex
that night i heard yeah you probably
heard us like before or after but steve
was just like
he's laughing like
but wait i feel like steve you avoided
scott's question was there anything that
lux wants to do that you're like whoa
that's a little too freaky for me
i mean i don't know lux wants to be more
uh experimental and she's like just tell
me like what
uh you know like what crazy [ __ ] she's
like i'll dress up like whatever like
you know like it let's [ __ ] right and
also in the beginning of our
relationship
i let you know that i also like women
and i was like so you know that and
you're like no i'm not into that
i don't think that there's anything
remotely healthy about uh threesomes in
uh a committed relationship
how many girls have you dated in the
past
uh
i don't know define date you mean like
how many persons
my number between men and women is is
pretty equal um i think steve pushed it
over to
have more for the men with steve
but it's pretty
neck and neck with men and women so like
like a hundred and fifty and a hundred
percent
straight on bisexual yeah are you still
find women attractive yeah of course
i find women more attractive than i do
men like for me to find a male
attractive they have to be like
just something about them or like really
[ __ ] good looking or like great like
there's it has to be most most guys that
girls are like oh he's so hot i'm like i
don't know
what's your type of woman
i mean i've been all over the spectrum
of like looks you like big boobs small
boobs big butt small butt skinny any of
that i like i like pretty girls with
like style who's your celebrity crush
a girl um
[Music]
angelina jolie yeah for sure number one
from day one very good and what about
for men
other than steve steven glover
so yeah it's more of a thinking thing
like i can think of like 20 girls but
for dudes
i think michael b jordan is handsome i
think he's pretty hot okay i mean he's
like epic
that's what i mean like
you know you know if i if i was gay dude
you know who i would go after a
celebrity who i think shyla buff really
wouldn't really probably he's like
that's a very interesting serious type
yeah that does a good looking dude he's
gotten ripped lately right but then he
didn't get into trouble with now if i
was gay yeah yeah
what about you
um
you you comment on men's attractive yeah
i mean i think yeah yeah i'm always
weighing in on on dudes
um
yeah which is cute which which of the
if you were if you had to date somebody
in the jackass crew who'd you date
looks
wise
um
i mean
knoxville is handsome you kind of gotta
go for knoxville right but i feel like
your chemistry with pontius
is kind of what would make a
relationship last
that's true
well yeah is this just a [ __ ] or is this
like a long lasting it's like mary yeah
[ __ ] mary kill
that'd be fun um i don't know
wait who's your who's your celebrity
crush
yeah i really like the girl for mad men
the redhead oh yeah i don't know her
name christina something hendrix
christina hendricks yeah okay what about
you paul i don't know rihanna has always
done it for me she's hot she's so
beautiful yeah when you like flawless
miley cyrus when you fly into like uh
barbados there's a big poster of rihanna
nice man she's hot as [ __ ] yeah she is
yeah
for dudes though i don't know brad pitt
has always kind of done it for me
but if you had to suck a celebrity
dude's dick yeah who would you choose
you could choose anyone but you're gonna
have to suck their dick this is a
complete treatment
complete
i might go with brad pitt yeah brad pitt
i feel like shia labeouf would just like
face [ __ ] me and like
that's kind of gnarly
i mean dude ryan reynolds is [ __ ] hot
dude he's got a great body i think he's
a body
and he's funny
he's hilarious
yeah and his face is gorgeous
and his body's like
jesus dude
yeah and he's a good kisser
so were you in a relationship with a
girl before you met steve like right
before was the transition from a girl to
steve no
no but you're gonna say something
but that was a
open relationship where it did date
women
yeah i feel like that would be hard to
be in an open relationship just because
it would never work it's tricky it's um
you know relationships are
tricky in general and so to add like
this other element um
i felt like for me the best
way to go about it
that i could like assess from the
beginning was like if the relationship's
having problems then it's closed if the
relationship is good and we're both in a
good spot then it's open again but
um
but that didn't work out so
yeah you're right i like you know i
agree with you on that one but what's
different about steve than anybody else
you dated why you know you're deciding
to marry him
it's like what was so special about him
yeah you know i never
cared about marriage or like getting
married or never thought about my
wedding day or anything like that
um no ever and then
really early on with you like
probably like june of 2017 i remember
thinking like
i want to marry this man like i want
that like
union with him like that like you know
bringing together of our lives and
[Music]
and i it was it was more about that than
like the wedding or anything so
i knew that pretty pretty early on it
wasn't i don't know just something i
realized
it's beautiful yeah yeah it's like when
you know you know kind of deal like
people always say that and then when did
you know
like june of that year when he first
went down and gave you a treatment
it was when um
it was when he
burned himself that happened on july 3rd
of 2017. in denver you flew out
yeah before that and then that happened
and then it was like
yeah it was a pretty heavy uh
that whole little like
time around me getting burned
um and having the skin graft surgery
was uh
intense man there's a lot of heavy stuff
kind of going on it was like this
perfect storm of like spirituality and
intensity and yeah you know commitment
and
and uh yeah i remember
it being around that time that uh
i had the idea that i wanted to ask you
to marry me but i knew that it wouldn't
be like
soon i just had the idea yeah and so i
got you to uh
get your ring sized like just as we're
like oh yeah like just you know which
was so cute you had no idea
no like we had talked briefly about like
i think in the hospital we had talked
about like
you know like this is new for us like we
don't we've never wanted to get married
but here we are like wanting that like
and just being okay with it you know
like
um
and then after we've been home and
you had something and
you like just were going to run in
really quick for 15 minutes i had an
appointment with my psychiatrist yes i
didn't want to tell your story but yeah
and you're like i think you know there's
probably like a jewelry store around
here like do you want to go get your
finger sized and i was just like well
that's [ __ ] cute
and um there were a ton of jewelry
stores around but it was in beverly
hills and i was just like
didn't i send you into a poncho i found
a pawn shop and i was like this is where
i'm gonna go and you text me you're like
did you find a store and i was like yeah
i'm at a pawn shop on the corner and
you're like oh i love it and so yeah
and then
and and and like uh i remember the
she told me the size
i remember and then like
what like a year later
however you know however however long
six months later
yeah six months later i'm going to go
get the engagement ring i tell the the
this engagement ring jeweler
her size
they refused to believe me they're like
no way that her finger's that small
you've totally remembered it wrong and
i'm like
no dude
and uh and i'm [ __ ] her ring's just
that small
yeah
but you do have an exceptionally
impressive memory
well thanks you know like
we'll be talking to him and he's like so
distracted and you think you didn't he
did he didn't even know you were talking
and then he'll get done with what he's
doing and then he'll be like he'll
repeat the exact verbatim question that
you asked him and then he'll answer it
and you're like what the [ __ ] how did
you do that like
like well you also asked me that
question in october of 2019 yeah
how many times does he like spitfire
dates just in this podcast yeah i know
or like you'll be like use the take
where i said like this one like very
minute little thing i'll be like oh okay
i think i remember you saying that and
like of course it's there and it's
right type you know yeah your memory is
crazy and which is impressive
just like you know at base and then then
after all the [ __ ] head trauma and
drugs right yeah it's it's yeah it's
crazy i mean i've smoked a lot of weed
and my memory is not as good as your my
memory is pretty good but it's still not
it's impressive
what is
i mean what's next for you guys
obviously
you know you talk about the the animal
sanctuary plan a lot
but have you guys narrowed it down to
where you think or is it for sure
since the idea has come up and and to
this day we had the idea
we thought about the animal sanctuary
being like this this non-profit
organization with all these revenue
streams to keep it going and it's a
destination where people come and visit
and
and all that and and during the pandemic
i just watching all the the stimulus
money and the trillions of dollars of
debt and it's just like all of the
speeding up of like yeah like what makes
america
uh precarious i think the american
economy and the dollar is like has been
precarious and considerably more so
after the
pandemic and i started looking to canada
you know
so uh like the canadian border has been
shut down i think it's starting to open
back up we
love the idea of going to go look there
and uh and and maybe if we get a
property in canada and and and turn it
into this fun farm it's more of a like a
self-sustainable farm right that kind of
runs itself and less
and more of like off the grid like
doomsday prepper kind of a farm type
deal where we just dip out
and don't want to draw any attention to
it right
um and that's kind of what it looks like
more but but whatever it does look like
we've we've uh really liked kind of
settled on the idea of getting married
on that property
and uh
well recently
we've been a little more yeah we've been
flexible with it just because we're so
busy right and hardly home which we love
our schedule we love our lives
and it's like okay realistically if we
had a home in canada
would we be there would we go there is
that right but then i saw this video
like called like how johnny knoxville
spends his 75 million dollars
and it and it's like well he bought the
this property in florida this property
in tennessee like he's gonna [ __ ] put
i never
heard anything about it until i saw that
video i'm like i said babe
you know
who cares if our schedule's busy like
i think that
like owning properties all over the
place might be
the call and i'm like cool i've been
telling you that for five years
rental properties or these animal
sanctuary properties uh i don't want to
be a landlord on any level like by the
idea of buying a property to rent out to
people so that you can right force but
forced to evict people who are down on
their luck i don't want to be so at the
very least it's an investment property
right investment property yeah but
that's not always the case and and i
think
if we buy a property in canada and and
turn into a farm and we're just too busy
to be there i want to have like a family
uh like
a family of farmers
like
some local
like thomas
yeah like ranchers
living there in the shed in the backyard
whatever like you know maybe maybe
there's some situation where like a a
you know a farmer and his family
like
have like
hit hard times and and like they need a
place to stay that they could stay on
our property like for free
and uh and just help kind of get it
going as a farmer land in the end yeah
some some sort of help like that is
probably going to be necessary anyway
right if you guys are going to have more
pretty standard for for large properties
it's like you know even if people sell
it's like the ranch hand usually stays
there because they know the land so well
and like have worked on it forever like
it's pretty common we're finding right
and it's got to have the the property in
in canada has to have
two
uh dwelling units it's got to be like
the main house and like the
you know the second house definitely so
this happens and certain and you know i
presume that people are probably
listening if there's people in british
columbia
listening
people
like uh they get the person to hit up
families and farmers
yeah
like hey the people if there's families
with farmers
in british columbia
they should dm luxe and be like hey so
this is like a six to 12 month plan like
but here's the things
we've targeted a date for our actual
wedding
right so but probably because
because we've right we're honing in on a
date which is exciting
but we talked about canada and then we
talked about the realization if we're
not there how much sense does it make so
then we're like oh maybe we'll get
married somewhere else and that's the
last
that we talked about it
steve's already made plans
i'm cool with like
yeah i want to get i want to get married
on a property in canada you want a big
wedding let's do it i want to get
married on a property in canada now that
we've said this and put this out into
the
the the the ether the the universe yep
like i think the people from british
columbia are going to be like hey like
we want to like get your property going
and and live there and where can they
find you to reach out to you lux
relaxing on my instagram looks a lot
lots
a lot less somebody my dad looked at my
instagram i said show dad an instagram
post and he's like oh like lux likes
that a lot
like liked by looks a lot yeah which is
great more than one like like by lux a
lot yeah yeah if i like it i like it a
lot
it's just no in-between so that's cool
so you guys yeah so it's canada huh big
weddings small wedding intimate tiny
small
yeah mm-hmm
how many bridesmaids you gonna have i
don't even i don't i mean you gotta have
bailey but here's that nicole here's the
thing you gotta have ashley yeah i love
all that and you gotta have monica
andrea and andre but here's the thing
yeah there it goes the thing is that
there are so many details uh and
decisions that go into wedding planning
that
i don't care about and so but that's
your job like you would love it because
it's you do it for work anyway right so
so that's the other thing is like i do
want it to be small
and intimate and
with what i do there's the other side
where i'm like i can
turn this into whatever the [ __ ] i want
and like make it like an experience and
i do
and i do like the idea of like
multiple day
thing where indian wedding yeah where
people come and like you know it's like
today we're doing this tomorrow we're
doing that you can join if you want but
everybody gets to know each other
beforehand and like you know establish
relationships so then when the wedding
actually happens then it's like so much
more intimate and fun colombian wedding
and
yeah and it's just you know it's like a
lot for one day i want it to be extended
like so there's i'm on the i'm on two
ends of this so it's like a canadian
wedding
this is the spectacular tuxedo everybody
wears jean suits would there be an open
bar at your wedding and would you be
weirded out people are like getting
[ __ ] up there and [ __ ] like that you
know there will be alcohol there paul if
that's your ass no no i'm just curious
psychedelics and whatever else your
friends
i don't think i i would care too much i
think anybody that i'm close enough with
that that they would be at my wedding
would be
respectful sure and i mean nobody ever
wants anyone to get super [ __ ] up at
their wedding and make a fool of
themselves anyway but i was just curious
you're i'm not particularly concerned i
mean with uh being around drinking
like dude for 10 years you know
10 years it's been comedy clubs and my
crowd drinks more than anybody's [ __ ]
crowd like i was just curious what i
don't like is breathing in people's weed
okay
if i'm breathing it in yeah like if
you've got a drink in your hand i'm not
drinking it
i don't care yeah
all right
well we have some wedding planning to do
then yeah
you plan it and i'll show up yeah
there's a gal planet scott
yeah that's true too so so we're getting
ready to shoot um one of our fun naked
photos i'm so excited is that gonna be
part of this podcast are you gonna show
it or where are you gonna show it thanks
i can't wait i think i i picture it
again can't wait post it immediately
once we oh well how excited you got it
yeah baby i love you i love you so much
thank you for having me i think i think
this was a really good podcast we should
do this again honestly this was really
fun i really liked it i want to keep
going
but you you're ready to go can you tell
with his body
yeah steve says forward
one hour like this that's another thing
that we have had to to like work on is
like we'll be at anywhere eating and
then he's done so he's like ready to go
and i'm still like drinking cool let's
go and then throws in the card he's
staying up and you're like
yeah like hello where's the awareness of
what
but your dad called you on that and
since your dad pointed it out and made
you feel like [ __ ] one time i think
you've been a lot better good
um you're gonna have to go we have a
meeting at two o'clock and you're gonna
go buy a gopro before then yeah welcome
there's a gopro somewhere in your house
there's like three of them all right how
do we get to the podcast
i love you honey and thank you for being
on the podcast i love you so much thanks
for having me you guys yeah can you do
an impression i want to see you guys do
like your your language
that or your language how you guys talk
to each other it's like
whatever
dude it's probably like steve will
accidentally
he'll accidentally text me one time i'm
like do you like it
i'm like bro and then he's like oh sorry
dude like wrong person i'm like what the
[ __ ] goes on here
[Laughter]
i'm really long
that's great
how about that dude is my girl dope or
what you know who else is dope
my man paul briskey
and he's got big news
it's a kid okay
it's that kid
it's that kid is you which is his
musical band
and their albums out dude
so [ __ ] come on what are you doing dude
do you not already have it dude are you
not a [ __ ] bro
i mean
come on dude let's support paul briskey
the gorgeous paul briskey and listen to
that kid is you that's the name of the
artist that kid is you
find it on spotify and
yeah find it everywhere the album's
argentina spotify apple music
it's called argentina and the band is
that kid is you so just look it up you
love it
thanks for [ __ ] sticking around guys
i love you